un procès sous haute surveillance un
moment espérée est redouté par plusieurs
c'est le temps de la justice
d'accord si la justice et à la justice
de faire son travail
pour respecter
patrick peloux a perdu des collègues
dans la tuerie de charlie hebdo
douze personnes abattues en quelques
minutes dont huit journalistes il n'y a
pas de frustration
c'est le temps de la justice lassana
bâti lee a aidé des otages a échappé aux
terroristes dans l'hyper cacher un héros
aux yeux de plusieurs français
c'est stressant mais c'est important
c'est important on attend ça depuis
longtemps
nous finançons ça ce sont trois journées
d'horreur qui ont marqué la france les
premiers d'une longue série d'attentats
dans le pays
les trois terroristes ont été tués par
les troupes d'élite dans le box des
présumés complices bien encadrés par des
policiers cagoulés pour protéger leur
identité mais ce ne sont pas des joueurs
de second plan cette avocate sont ce ces
attaques n'aurait pas été perpétrés sur
le territoire français donc oui il faut
les condamner sévèrement les condamnés
parce que le terrorisme se nourrit de la
délinquance s'est accusé plusieurs ont
tenu à les voir de près
comme cette femme dont le mari a été tué
dans les locaux de charlie hebdo
je voulais justement voir des personnes
en box des accusés pour savoir ce qu'il
représente comment ils sont des accusés
qui on peut parler aujourd'hui
la cour a entendu les principales
conclusions des enquêteurs s'étaient
sans grands détails mais visiblement
c'était trop pénible pour certains comme
la mère de l'un des responsables de
charlie hebdo un long procès débute un
procès sur lequel bien des gens fonde
beaucoup d'espoir le verdict dans ce
procès est attendu début novembre soit
quelques jours avant le cinquième
anniversaire d'un autre attentat
sanglant celui du bataclan ici lien
exhumant baron radio-canada paris